Christopher Lee is most familiar to the
world as a consummate actor with a deep
rich voice and a towering presence in 10
Hammer Studios films he became the
embodiment of evil inhabiting the
character of Count von Dracula with a
sinister charm then breaking the mold he
went on to play some of the most iconic
characters in cinematic history yet who
would've known that the great character
actor was a former world war ii RAF
intelligence officer and Nazi hunter who
had been a witness to unspeakable
atrocities in this week's biographic s--
we Pierce the celluloid to discover the
real Christopher Lee Christopher Frank
carandini Lee was born on May the 27th
1922 in Belgravia in London his father
Geoffrey was a hero of the First World
War
having been decorated for gallantry at
the Battle of the Somme at the time of
his son's birth he was a left-hand
colonel on the King's Royal Rifle Corps
Geoffrey was married to an Italian
countess by the name of Estelle Murray
blessed with great beauty stars heritage
traced all the way back to Emperor
Charlemagne
as a result the Leigh household was
frequently visited by high-ranking
figures of European nobility and the
young Christopher came into contact with
some very interesting and important
people
Christopher was the Lee's second child
where the sisters Zandra having been
born in 1917 however the marriage it was
not a happy one and when the boy was
just four years old his parents
separated for the next two years the
children lived with Estelle in Wengen
Switzerland while their father remained
in the Belgravia house after two years
the marriage officially ended while in
switzerland Estelle enrolled her son in
a preschool called miss Fisher's Academy
which was located in Tara tete it was
here that Christopher was given his
first acting role appearing as the lead
character in the play Rumpelstiltskin in
1928 Estella the children returned to
England Christopher was put into Agnes
private school in Queensgate London in
1929 Estelle married a banker by the
name of Harcourt Georgeson Crewe Rose
Leigh's stepfather happened to be the
uncle of a young
writer named Ian Fleming who would go on
to create not only James Bond but also
bonds arch-nemesis Scaramanga or the man
with the Golden Gun who Lee would
famously play on film a half-century
later following the marriage the family
moved to Fulham at the age of nine
Christopher was enrolled at summer
fields a boarding school in Oxford he
enjoyed his time at summer fields and
quickly made friends and proved himself
to be a gifted and studious people among
his closest friends of summer fields was
Patrick McNeil who would also carve a
career as an actor and find fame as
secret agent John Steed in the Avengers
the ins McNee both enjoyed acting and
appeared in the number of school plays
together summer fields was a feeding
school to Eton College and in 1935
Christopher sent the scholarship exam
and was interviewed by the school
Provost
however his maths ability let him down
and he missed out on a scholarship by
one place if he was to attend Eton his
family would have to pay his way despite
his mother's urgings his stepfather was
unwilling to foot the bill sue ended up
at Wellington College in Berkshire it
was at Wellington that Lee proved
himself to be a brilliant linguist he
mastered French Spanish Italian and
German and gained a passing knowledge of
Swedish Greek and Russian yet despite
his academic prowess he chafed under the
harsh discipline that was meted out at
the school he hated the irregular
parades and weapons training that became
more and more regular as talk of war
became more frequent in political
circles so it was with some relief that
he had to leave Wellington when his
stepfather went bankrupt in 1939
[Music]
the 17 year olds education was over he
was now expected to make his own way in
the world but he entered the job market
just as the summer holidays were
beginning and there were no prospects
after a month of fruitless job hunting
he was allowed to join his sister who
was on holiday on the French Riviera
while there Lee heard news that the last
public execution in France was to take
place in Paris along with thousands of
others who took the trip to witness the
gruesome events from Paris he traveled
to mentor in southern France there he
stayed with an exiled Russian princely
family with ties to his mother he
enjoyed his time there meant wanted to
stay but with Europe about to erupt into
warfare it was decided that he would be
better off back in the relative safety
of London for a short time he worked as
a clerk in a shipping line office when
war broke out in September of 1939 Lee
was eager to do his part too young to
join the Regular Army he teamed up with
some friends and travelled to Finland
with plans to fight aside the Finns
in their struggle against Russia the
British teens may have had a lot of
fighting spirit but none of them knew
how to ski which rendered them virtually
useless in the snow-covered battle
terrain they were politely thanks for
their assistance and then strongly
encouraged to return to England back in
London Lee resumed his work as an office
clerk in 1940 at the age of 18 he joined
the Home Guard it was around this time
that his father Jeffrey died though he
had great respect for his father's
wartime endeavors Christopher had no
desire to follow his footsteps into the
Regular Army
knowing that conscription was not far
away he decided to enter the armed
services on his terms
consequently he volunteered to fight in
the Royal Air Force
[Music]
following his initial training Niwas
stations to southern rhodesia on the
brink of his first solo flying mission
he complains of blackouts and blurred
vision he was diagnosed with a failed
optic nerve and told that he would never
fly again for a number of months he was
transferred around the RAF service in
Africa that given nothing meaningful to
do then out of frustration he applied to
the RAF intelligence service gaining
entry to the service he was posted as a
water to the Salisbury prison in
Rhodesia from there he was moved to the
Suez Canal Zone where he was put to work
in intelligence gathering activities
during the North African campaign he was
deeply involved as part of number 260
squadron RAF nearly losing his life when
an airfield was destroyed by a German
bombing rate in the winter of 1943 Lee
was part of an officer swap and he was
seconded to the army he spent the next
year serving with the Gurkhas of the 8th
Indian Infantry Division he saw action
in the Battle of Monte Cassino almost
losing his life when a plane crashed on
takeoff towards the end of 1944 he was
promoted to flight left Tennant and
posted to Air Force HQ when the ends of
hostilities finally came in April of
1945 he was given a position in the
central registry of war criminals of
security suspects he had become
essentially a Nazi hunter the work was
top-secret and we have a few specifics
about what he did in a later interview
however he did say this we were given
dossiers of what they're done and told
to find them interrogate them as much as
we could and hand them over to the
appropriate authority we saw these
concentration camps some had been
cleaned up somewhat not
[Music]
they left the army in 1946 after what he
had experienced over the previous few
years he could no longer bring himself
to work in an office he had the
opportunity to teach classics at
university but didn't fancy that
prospect either unsure what to make of
his post military life the 24-year old
found himself dining of the Italian
embassy in London with his cousin the
Italian ambassador to England
Niccolo carandini out of the blue
carandini looked at me and said have you
ever thought of being an actor taken a
little off-guard by this me replies no
wait don't think so carandini then
replied perhaps when you go away you
might want to think about it let's think
about it he did he decided that he quite
liked the idea and mentioned it to his
mother the countess however was
vehemently opposed a career in acting
was beneath her status she employed and
besides at 6 feet 5 he was too tall it
was also to foreign looking and he was
hardly a steady line of work but the
more pre railed against the acting idea
the more her son became determined to
make a success of it towards the end of
1946 he joined the rancor company of
youth in the next few years he busied
himself learning the craft of acting he
swept the theater stage held prompt
cards for the actors on stage and
eventually got tiny parts himself then
came small roles in films his height did
indeed work against him with casting
directors struggling to find a place for
him however the roles did come directors
managed to find creative ways to hide
his height such as having him sit during
his scenes some of his roles in these
early years were uncredited while others
ended up on the cutting room floor but
they all added to the skills that he
would display when the big roles
eventually came around
[Music]
in 1957 Lee was hired by hammer film
productions for his biggest party yet he
was to play the monster created by Baron
von Frankenstein who was to be played by
his good friend Peter Cushing the movie
called the curse of Frankenstein found
any immediate audience among lovers of
horror who clamored for more Hammer
decided to satisfy the demand with a
cinematic take on the Bram Stoker
classic Dracula with me in the lead role
the movie released in 1958 was a huge
hit with these sinister yet charming
take on the fangs count Forever
embedding itself in the public
consciousness Dracula
that was the movie that turns the
struggling 36 year old journeyman actor
into a star he later recalls it's
brought me a name a fan club and a
second-hand car for all of which that
was grateful the Dracula movie was both
a blessing and a curse fully it's
inevitably typecast him and it tied him
to appear in a succession of sequels
each one worse than the last
when he tried to bring the series to an
ends he was in his own words blackmailed
by hammer executives who would remind
him how many people he would put out on
the street if the next movie was not
made Lee played the part of Dracula 10
times and increasingly grew tired of the
shadow that had cast over his career it
took eight years for the second Dracula
to be released by which time the first
movie had made a tremendous impact all
over the world yet when Lee was handed
the script for the sequel he was
horrified not by the murderous things
that his character was asked to do but
by the terrible dialogue that he had
been given as a result he refused to do
the lines which is why Dracula does not
say a single word in 1965 Dracula Prince
of Darkness he was also concerned that
the character of crack allah was getting
further and further away from what Bram
Stoker had in mind when he wrote the
book
[Music]
you
according to the man himself Lee's real
career as a serious actor started when
he was cast as the Mucky too sad in a
tale of two cities in 1958 this was in
fact his 43rd movie other serious roles
followed but he was unable to escape the
horror genre for over a decade appearing
in a slew of largely forgettable
blood-and-guts flicks both for hammer
studios and other production companies
in 1962 Lee auditioned for a role in the
world war two classic the longest day it
is ironic that despite his distinguished
service for his country during the
actual war he was turned down because it
was felt that audiences wouldn't accept
him as a military-type from 1965 until
1969 leave despite his obvious english
barring starred in a series of movies in
which he played the villainous oriental
fu-manchu's his skill as an actor along
with long hours in the makeup chair
allowed him to breathe life into the
role of the criminal mastermind in 1970
Lee picked up a single day's work as the
narrator in a film about the Marquis de
Sade
entitled Eugenie it was only when the
movie was released that he realized he
was appearing in a soft porn film loaded
with sex scenes that were shot when he
wasn't around he was embarrassed and he
was angry but he couldn't really do much
about it Lee credits his role as
Sherlock Holmes's smart older brother
Mycroft in the 1970s movie the private
life of Sherlock Holmes as the role that
allowed him to finally break free from
being typecast as the horror guy three
years later he played Lord summer Isle
in what is considered the best movie he
ever made The Wicker Man but he was so
taken with the book ritual upon which
the movie is based that he offered his
services free of charge
the film has become a cult classic and
it is considered one of the best British
movies ever made in the mid 1970s Lee
appeared as Comte a rush for in the
three musketeers and its sequel The Four
Musketeers during a fight scene he
received knee injury which would plagued
him for the rest of his life back in the
early 60s please stamp Carson Ian
Fleming who had made it big as an author
had offered him the role of the
villainous title character in the movie
adaptation of his James Bond novel dr.
know Lee accepted the role on the spot
however Fleming hadn't cleared Lee with
the producers and they had already
chosen their man a dozen years later
they finally got his chance when he
landed the role of Francisco Scaramanga
in the tenth Bond film the man
with the Golden Gun Lee breathed life
into this character as well who Fleming
had written as a rather bland bad guy
lacking any real depth the writer was
delighted with the portrayal claiming
that Lee had created the sinister
counterpart to James Bond by 1977 Lee
had established a reputation as a fine
actor who could take on any role and
make it his own still he was concerned
that if he remains in England he would
eventually be lured back into the dark
tunnel of horror movies avoiding that
fate was the prime motivation for his
move to the United States in 1977 his
first American role was a departure from
anything that had gone before the modern
day disaster Airport 77 the following
year he went even further beyond his
comfort zone and appeared as the guest
host on NBC live comedy show Saturday
Night Live he remembers the experience
as the most terrifying hour and a half
of his life that night though he
impressed many people including budding
director Steven Spielberg who promptly
signed him up for his next project the
period comedy in 1941 Lee had the chance
to follow up with another comedy a spoof
of Airport 77 called
airplane but he turned the role down and
he went to Leslie Nielsen Lee would
later refer to this decision as a big
mistake through the 1980s and 90s Lee
appeared in a broad spectrum of movie
genres from dramas to comedies and even
musicals
he also made regular appearances on the
small screen for both British and
American television audiences in 1998
Lee was controversially cast as Muhammad
Ali Jinnah the founder of Pakistan in
the movie Jinnah it was to be his most
demanding role and the one that carried
the most responsibility for 10 weeks he
acted the part of the father of the
Pakistani nation on location as
thousands of locals scrutinized his
every move the vast majority of them
were won over by the consummate actor
amazed and delighted with his ability to
become Jinnah the movie was hugely
important to Lee but it did not achieve
widespread commercial success
[Music]
Lee had been a lifelong fan of the j.r.r
tolkien Lord of the Rings series of
books reading them annually at once
actually met Tolkien and for decades had
harbored the desire to play the role of
Gandalf what he was offered and
immediately accepted was the part of
Saruman in the trilogy to be directed by
New Zealand director Peter Jackson the
role brought him to a new generation of
fans who were enthralled with his
commanding performance those who were
privileged to work with him on the set
were also captivated by the Christopher
Lee aura in one scene
Saruman was to be stabbed in the back
and director Jackson coached Lee to
scream as the blade entered his body Lee
turned to Jackson and asked him if it
ever actually seen a man get stabbed in
the back Jackson admitted that he hadn't
- which Lee said well I have and I know
what to do he went on to explain that
such a wound would puncture the lungs
preventing the person from screening at
best they would basically let out a
quiet groan with this revelation the set
went quiet all-present knew that they
were in the presence of a man who had
lived through things that they could
only imagine the success of The Lord of
the Rings movies led to Lee's insertion
into the Star Wars franchise where he
plays the evil Count Dooku throughout
the 2000s he also appeared in a string
of Tim Burton movies including Sleepy
Hollow and Sweeney Todd the Demon Barber
of Fleet Street
[Music]
in 2011 Lee embraced his roots by
appearing in his first Hammer film in 35
years the residents along with Hilary
Swank while filming in Mexico he
suffered a back injury and had to
undergo surgery as a result he was
unable to play a leading role in the
long-awaited sequel to the Wickerman
entitled the wicker tree however he was
determined to appear in the film and was
given a small role as the mentor of the
character he was meant to play although
in his late 80s Lee was insistent that
he had no intentions of retiring from
acting he often said that making movies
had never been a job to him it was his
life it gave him meaning and it gave him
purpose with respiratory problems and
dodgy heart he couldn't accept as many
roles as he had in earlier days still he
was kept busy with voiceover work and
narration work and at least one major
production each year his final movie was
an independent production called angels
of nothing he'll Christopher Lee died on
June the 27th 2015 at the age of 93 the
official cause of death was heart
failure in the tributes that flowed he
was recognized as appearing in 208 films
more than anyone else in history those
myriad roles allow him to live on
enabling his millions of fans both old
and new to experience the presence of a
true giant of cinema so I really hope
you enjoyed that episode of biographic
if you did there's a couple of things
you could do right now one is hit that
like button below also if you want more
stuff like this we put out brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on YouTube if you actually want to
get a notification about these videos
please do hit that Bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send
you a notification every time every
Monday and Thursday won't put out a new
video also if you want to watch
something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]
you